hello welcome to see a plane Grandmaster
em GUI is that bothers really Mekhi
garage love live in Brussels Wow Jaeger
which is somewhat of a living legend
actually Ethan is 50 has now been a
absolute world class player for quite a
long time in the 1980s and 90s been a
second to too many strong brand masters
and kind of stunt that he plays on the
ICC he's also which is quite quite funny
it's also the first Grand Master that
had that I have beaten in tournament
share that also the strongest at the
time he was just 2600 is he was higher
for a long long period of time being
also about 2,700 at 11 point so this is
a main line of the English opening by
transposition he got there like a ghost
bishop age 3 here after okay one black
can go would be a door take um both as
possible okay rook e1 he played yeah I
wonder how this is actually played
bishop age three he has bishop age 12
keep this on the board but I still think
I should do that hmm so what to do I
wonder if f5 is really an option here on
just just a useless idea
not quite sure bull which is a great
expert on the English so he here
absolutely knows what he's doing here so
um yeah f5 f5 looks very caveman but I
don't know let's do it
the game that I won against him back in
nineteen ninety seven or 1996 not it's
been a long time that was also i was
attacking his King and I got a checkmate
they got a check made it with a pretty
direct attack so I'm going for one going
towards his King here at least yeah
White's main idea just to just be a
little bit less week until Black has
some weaknesses him and my bishop is
stranded c5 is a move that could be
quite annoying something to check maybe
it takes Quinn bah no I place that in a
very patient fashion probably correctly
so if I go f4 I wonder that is an idea
it gains some space but it gives up the
e4 square which is not exactly
attractive hmm yeah this is something
that I wasn't quite sure how to react to
c5 to a for my v7 porn is weak here it
really is it tries to check and take on
c7 Quincy some alien queen a form here a
little bit under pressure here
absolutely I wonder maybe i can go
Bishop g4 h5 f7 that would be very
useful
okay i don't i don't see a concrete
threat at the moment so maybe i can do
that
check
be sure over to f7 that would be helpful
to defend to defend my position a little
bit I've gotten more space but he's got
he's got more to attack here so you in a
three and said the thing hmm hmm I can
go see 5 i'm a time
does he have another India Bishop 854
and probably not
and I didn't expect that said said
really all they're threatening now we
wants to once the trade and then get to
get to attack this okay if I take I'm
losing stuff so I cannot take you should
f7 maybe and at the end is got time
working we should see 7 + icon no I
cannot 25 that's surprisingly annoying
move which I took far too long to answer
hmm took far too long to answer that
you
is it ticking you five takes takes is a
double check
oh wow he really really got me here yeah
and this kind of position is a little
bit better for Wired simply because it's
it's it's more compact yeah you have
more stuff to defend with black and it's
not it's not that easy especially with
this limited time that you form the day
okay now okay I'll lose on time here
check your strange technical flavored at
least didn't quite get it check check
black for a fence on time Joan here I
would let me nicely there on the
queenside gem this is a theoretical
position and this is a position that i
have in my wide repertoire for that
mentioned or mentioning is english
series simply because those positions
are a little bit easier for wider plane
because it's rather black who can
overextend and I did alway extension in
some way it's it's not like like it's
terribly were cm it's just that it's not
so easy to keep this this is harmonized
to this position and Kim he's just
creeping slowly toward my position yeah
that wasn't incredibly annoying new here
and here I'm probably I'm okay here okay
I didn't see why ah because I take you
to so I can just take and do this
because this isn't all that much because
he to Hanks ah so well okay i mean i was
on the pressure the whole time so i
didn't i didn't see it this is this is
just blundering then but yeah if you
under pressure the whole time it's not
an easy easy position to
I at least her not for me he did a
really nice job down yeah that line can
be recommended this is general this line
can it can happen from various moves
orders and it's it's the kind of
position where you can do do something
with wine without risking anything it's
a very fitting part of an English
repertoire ok guys thanks for watching